[Music]
in
english only news submitted by arrow
hero harrow he's a [ __ ] bee
man god damn it where right there
um a director at duke university has
stepped down after an email she sent to
students was like
i read this [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] finish your
sentence
go ahead finish yourself it was linked
online [ __ ] i was like
some nudes no her email she emailed
she emailed some students or something
like don't speak a chinese
but that's not okay let's talk about it
you talk about it i haven't really
looked into it i have to hold myself
because i don't want to interrupt you i
love it when you do my job for me
i know so you can do it just kidding
i'll read it
all right careful what you say girl i'm
not trying to have him say it i want it
i'm more entertaining i know
just to let you know all right so duke
university removed the head
of master a master's program so
it's for the biometrics you okay
i just know what's gonna happen that's
why i'm laughing
okay so it's the director of graduate
studies master of biostatistics program
department of biostatistics and bio
blah blah blah okay so the got it the
email says
hi all i had two separate faculty
members come to my office today and ask
if i had pictures of the mb students i
shared with them the head shots of the
first and second year cohorts
taken during orientate orientation both
faculty members picked out a small group
of first-year students who they observed
speaking chinese parentheses in their
words
very loudly in all kinds of cantonese
for sure yeah for sure
in this or korean there's a chinese
though
honestly yeah yeah right you guys are
loud no
oh you've never spoken korean that low
what are you talking about yes i have no
you haven't
i just don't remember korean students
speaking very very loud loud
yeah we're actually very embarrassed of
ourselves all the time it's part of our
culture it's like japanese and korean
culture
only no only at the bar yeah at the
bottom
at the korean barbecue at the bar but
then at school
like the korean exchange students were
always really quiet in your [ __ ] face
dude
all right cory up forever
all right so continuing it says uh so
observe speaking chinese in their words
very loudly in the student lounge
study areas i asked why they were
curious about the students names
both faculty members replied that they
wanted to write down the names so they
could remember them if the students ever
interviewed for an internship or asked
to work with them for a master's project
and then this yeah that sucks trying to
single them out yeah this next sentence
is in bold and
underlined it says they were
disappointed that these students were
not taking the opportunity to improve
their english
and were being so impolite as to have a
conversation that not everyone on the
floor could understand
what yeah
continues to international students
to international students and then all
caps
please please please keep these
unintended consequences
in mind when you choose to speak in
chinese in the building i have no idea
how hard it
it has been and still is for you to come
to the us
and have to learn a non-native language
as such i have the utmost respect for
what you're doing
that being said i encourage you to
commit to using english 100
of the time when you are in hawk or any
other professional setting
copying the second year students as a
reminder given that they are currently
applying for jobs happy to discuss
more just stop by my office megan neely
huh i think it's something
sand cans if somebody said that
somebody if i read that that would only
make me want to speak louder in the most
obnoxious way possible
yeah because it's like you don't tell me
what i should speak or don't speak dude
i wouldn't i wouldn't even be a chinese
student i would take a cantonese class
for two years
just to come back so i could speak as
loud as possible dad petty level 1000 i
like it i like that
you know i mean what you know what's
really petty are the two teachers
that made their way that asked for the
picture and that
so they could [ __ ] remember to like
make sure that they don't get a job or
get to where they want to go
but they got more important things to do
[ __ ] is that what the [ __ ] is that
and in the i i mean i'm glad that the
[ __ ] head
stepped down because that email was a
[ __ ]
dumbasses email like how did you how did
you even work at
duke university dude i'm gonna get
one of the students that knows how to
play that [ __ ] annoying chinese
guitar and start doing folk music
in the backseat that's like a little old
chinese like the [ __ ]
chinese violin and i'm going to do
chinese opera dude
here's the whole outfit the king's
outfit oh [ __ ] dude
and i'm going to start stir-frying [ __ ]
in the middle of the
[ __ ] like area
[Laughter]
in that [ __ ] town to go out in the
halls and smoke cigarettes while they're
crouching down and have big-ass
you want to see chinese yeah we'll show
you [ __ ] chinese
dude you sure it's tied up with the
belly button easy dude
i'm cutting ducks next and i'm hanging
that [ __ ] up
now we keep the heads on man oh yeah
dude yeah easy dude she [ __ ] up so bad
because her
her plan uh backfired because what she's
trying to do
is get rid of the chinese right but she
doesn't understand
how chinese logic works so what happens
is
she causes all this negative attention
being drawn to duke
so now all the white kids that we're
gonna apply like oh my god i'm not gonna
be in such an
insensitive school we're gonna apply
somewhere else and all the chinese kids
i'm like
yeah my chance all the white people are
not applying
to be flocks of chinese kids applying to
duke yeah
there's gonna be three times the
population oh my god it's gonna be all
louis vuitton wrapped lamborghinis in
the [ __ ] park
gonna smell like cilantro and ankle
ankle [ __ ] cigarettes
ankle or some [ __ ] cigarettes you don't
know what the [ __ ] you did dude
a tiny spice spice it's gonna be dale
university
i bet you this dumbass thinks that she
was being i bet you this dumbass thinks
that she was being like
super polite by saying i understand what
you guys
are going through yeah she tries it must
be so
hard she's fake and it's like [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up that doesn't [ __ ] balance
nothing
kind of imagine what she looks like let
me see if i'm right you can't imagine
i can kind of tell what she looks like
okay this is me that's exactly what she
looks like that's a deborah oh
that's a [ __ ] why are your eyes so
close together [ __ ]
i'm sorry her name's what megan megan
your jacket megan why does she look like
a bootleg
why are your eyes coming close together
high five each other [ __ ] she looks
like a bootlegger eyebrows
she has not eyebrows no she's gone
no eyebrow having [ __ ] well that's the
eyebrow that's bootleg hillary clinton
no
damn you guys are sad it is yeah your
kids are gonna grow up to be rapists
this was the photo of the first year
student yeah there's hella asians in
there yeah you [ __ ] up that's all
asian people dude nobody wants to major
bio statistics the most boring thing on
earth one
at least one of them has a supreme
backpack you know it
i mean you know what the problem is like
i don't really get it were they
were they [ __ ] loud in the classroom
were they allowed in the study area
okay so tell them don't speak loud
in the study area don't [ __ ] be like
don't speak chinese
because if they're international
students here's what i notice about a
lot of international students
not all of them are great at english
because they're international students
right so then they hook up with other
students that can speak that language
or or maybe one is like they know
english a little bit more than the other
one
and then they're talking it out they're
they're [ __ ] helping each other and
all that [ __ ]
so it's like you're also hurting their
[ __ ] schooling because of that
but just tell them don't [ __ ] talk
loud yeah that's the only issue
on that not the don't speak chinese
english teacher and they're not english
majors so she shouldn't be concerned
with
oh you come to this country i know it's
so hard how are you supposed to better
the english language if that you're not
practicing it's like [ __ ] that's a
cover up i don't care bio statistics
dude that's english it's number terms i
don't care man
i don't know cover-up for someone who's
mad that there's so many asians in duke
university
yeah yep and they want it to be like oh
you know this is [ __ ] american so
speak american
yeah we'll have more fun majors then
dude stupid
why don't you get mad at the [ __ ]
school for bringing in
international students that's who you
should get mad at not the [ __ ] kids
that are just
enjoying their [ __ ] college life in a
different country
you know learning a new language and
[ __ ] yeah so the students
uh they they came together and they
organized the petition asking the
university to look into
neely and the treatment of international
students and then they wrote
uh we are disheartened when duke when
duke faculty members implied that
students of diverse
national origin
would be punished when you
faculty member implied that students of
diverse national origin would be
punished in academic and employment
opportunities for speaking in their
native language
outside of classroom settings we are
demoralized even more
that a new graduate program director
explicitly condones and even encourages
such discriminatory practices by our
faculty members
even the thunder don't like you [ __ ] and
she's
dumb too because technically if a
majority of the people in your graduate
program are chinese maybe you should
learn cantonese
oh yeah or she jumped into her shed away
for the korean student to come
out hey this is the library
she's gonna just wait five more minutes
in a little korean fun
hey this is a library
you can watch asian asian wars in there
yeah oh
that'd be [ __ ] hilarious yeah so then
the dean
she announced that neely would be
stepping down as a director
and then that an investigation would be
launched to determine
quote ways in which we can improve the
learning environment for students from
all backgrounds
sadly this matter demonstrates that we
must continue to work on overcoming deep
seated concerns about our cultural
awareness and understanding we take this
challenge seriously and
you have my personal pledge that it will
be addressed quickly and simple yeah i
mean i don't think this girl's racist at
all
i just think yeah she's one she's stupid
and she just
doesn't well this is actually the second
email she's probably gonna grow up in a
diverse
area i don't think she has bad intent in
that way
where she's like [ __ ] all these [ __ ]
ching chongs she also has a face that no
one would hire though that's
true the only other time i've ever seen
that face is that sees candy
so this was actually the second email
that she sent out to the school because
the first one was a year almost a year
ago
with the subject line to speak or not to
speak english
and then it said um she should be like a
dmv employee
yeah she's like the type of tire [ __ ]
you know what i can solve the problem
pretty [ __ ] easy though all you have
to do
is tell the [ __ ] chinese students to
go study at the smoking area
and that's pretty much good dude oh so
convenient
just want to get reading books i
understand if she's telling american
citizens hey man
you know it's about time you guys learn
some english but like if these are
international students
she still can't even say that i wouldn't
want to hear that either
well it makes more sense that's what i'm
saying like it's it's not right to tell
them what they have to be speaking
but it makes way more sense instead of
international students they're going to
go back to
[ __ ] whatever country they're here
studying abroad whatever like
that's this is not their primary
language for sure in that first email
she wrote
quote speaking in your native language
may give faculty the impression that
you're not trying to improve your
english skills
so like she's so worried about no she's
not this is elementary school she's
still
the [ __ ] she's trying to i don't think
any faculty member has ever thought to
themselves oh my god
though ling ling's not speaking english
today what do i do
like no one is concerned about that dude
i would just if it was just a normal
[ __ ] email where it's like hey
can all the students that are allowed as
[ __ ] to shut the [ __ ] up yeah yeah and
that makes sense that should be fine
then it came out that they were trying
to she could be she could be like yo
like you guys are second year or
whatever like teach the newcomers how we
do things here
like that would have been way different
because she [ __ ] up like i i had a
boss once that she
for some reason felt that it was so
important that
everyone during their lunch break still
had to speak english because everyone
spoke spanish
exactly she's like well you're in
america you should be speaking english
and i'm like what the [ __ ] like
this is not work time like we're not
talking about work workings
my business jealous because you can't
speak another language [ __ ] you
and you want to be nosey no one wants to
be i mean there's one
like for professional conduct is not you
know she's trying to impose her
cultural ideals of what should be
american or whatever right and then
she's in there trying to tell you to
speak english
during lunch when it's your time i don't
know about that
yep i don't know about that i'm wearing
chocolates to work
[ __ ] only button up the top button
little yeah you should just [ __ ] wear
a poncho over your scrub
scrub so i'm like we couldn't do that or
get
oh damn oh see even the
yeah damn even the mexican lightning
said
okay okay don't [ __ ] with mexican
lightning
it's spicier
[Music]
you